aliens the Chinese
Harold's private jet
the pressure building on President Biden
to come clean to the American people and
explain what the heck is going on in our
skies the U.S military shooting down a
fourth object making it three
unidentified objects that have been
taken out in the last three days the
first one was that Chinese spy balloon
the White House can't seem to get the
story straight but don't worry at least
it's not E.T
there is no again no indication of
aliens or extraterrestrial activity with
these recent takedowns I don't think the
American people need to worry about
aliens with respect to these craft
period I don't think there's any more
that needs to be said there a lot of
growing questions but as usual the Biden
White House not a lot of answers and
don't expect to hear from the president
we have not yet been able to definitely
definitively assess what these most
recent objects are we don't know what
this exactly looked like and again we're
still not sure exactly what what it what
the purpose of it was or who owned it
but we're going to learn more I'd rather
not go into any more detail than that
we're sort of in Uncharted Territory
here no pun intended but we don't you
know we don't we don't know I won't
speak for the president's uh personal uh
speaking schedule but I mean he has been
deeply engaged in uh every one of these
decisions he's been kept informed and
Biden silence isn't just worrying the
American people a bipartisan group of
lawmakers is demanding answers
I have real concerns about why the
administration is not being more
forthcoming with everything that it
knows the invite Administration needs to
stop briefing Congress through our
television sets and actually come and
sit down and brief us the military needs
to have a plan to not only determine uh
what's out there but determine the
dangers that go with it I believe the
American people are owed an explanation
if they're serious enough for us to send
fighter jets out to shoot down then I
think it's uh it's okay for the American
people to know who's behind this
so if it flies it dies and we don't know
where these things are coming from or
will that remember it only if it flies
it dies only after one was able to go
across the United States for a week and
they said there was no concern there was
no problem and they just wanted to shoot
it down afterwards well all of a sudden
then they said well we open our aperture
a little bit more and turns out there's
a whole bunch more of these things going
up there which means our Radar Radar
wasn't working before or it wasn't and
they have left the American people
hanging for three days and then to
condescendingly blow them off when
somebody says is it aliens like how are
we supposed to know logically I've never
believed in UFOs or aliens but if you
don't tell anybody anything and then
you're going to sit back and go like oh
these people they're so silly you're so
ridiculous how could you possibly
believe that and make fun of them I
don't like that I don't think that was a
good look and it's just unidentified
flying object Greg and Trudeau the prime
minister of Canada for people who don't
know he had a big statement let's listen
yesterday NORAD confirmed that an
unidentified object entered unlawfully
Canadian airspace
it represented a reasonable threat to
civilian aircraft
so I gave the order to take it down now
the aliens are scared now she's a
regular Churchill he just went he said I
want that weather balloon out of our
space let's take it down boys that was a
moment of heroism I won't soon forget
you know what he probably he probably
thought there was a trucker in there
you're right you know um
I heard that the uh uh well anyway I
won't make any more jokes about him um
they're shooting down her old stuff
that's all this is right we we there was
a couple years ago it was reported that
we had all these surveillance balloons
going around it was in the guardian I
think I think what this is is like
you're right they're trying to prove
that we aren't weak and we aren't
vulnerable so now we're just gonna shoot
everything we see and it's a very
expensive way of getting rid of old
surveillance balloons I don't know how
much a missile costs but I mean it's got
isn't it like a million dollars a
missile it's a pretty expensive way to
get rid of your trash and it's it's
basically Space trash but I just I just
I loved how he had to get the space
let's be honest he had to get permission
from the United States is it okay if I
get to shoot one down please Daddy
please Daddy will you let me shoot it
down okay you can shoot one down I might
even do it in black people is gonna
probably
say what about me judge what's going on
here you know what I think is amazing
that the president has said nothing okay
so the American people and by the way I
want to say I don't I don't believe in
UFOs either but there is apparently a
number of UFO sighting between March 21
and 22
247 mostly reported by the Navy and Air
Force pilots okay I mean there is
something that's why they had to deny it
but here's the the outrageous part why
do people in Congress why are they not
sitting down with the president why is
the president not talking to America why
is he not look if he's got such Verve
and so vibrant for the
commander-in-chief get the hell out
there and talk to us all right but more
than that General Kellogg today was
talking about how low the soldier morale
is given the fact that nobody knows what
they're doing and as Dana said they
opened the aperture and now oh geez
there's more of these things but think
about what they said last week with the
one that crossed across the country
these are quotes we use the time to
analyze it we did and we knew where it
was going we did so then why did you
take it down over the ocean where you
can't get part of it because it's too
low so now they're hovering over these
maneuverable with their maneuverable
spycraft strategic Command Center
Nebraska intercontinental ballistic site
in Montana to improve targeting
information or to intercept
communication now the question now is
what is the protocol I asked for this on
Friday is the protocol to shoot
everything down do we know what we're
supposed to shoot down and now are we so
connected to China that we trade is the
best it's ever been and we've got all of
these we've got all these codependencies
where we rely on our medication from
China that we can't disconnect from them
is that what this is all about that
Biden's afraid to come out and say
something and then Austin comes out
today an hour ago and he says our policy
hasn't changed at all what are you
talking about our policy was never to
shoot this stuff down which is why you
let the one hover across the United
States that they're totally caught off
guard they're reactive they don't know
what they're doing Jesse no one's asking
the big question what's that what's an
aperture
we're going to find that out afterwards
you don't know what it is either do you
she said it first then she said it you
don't know what it is you know what an
aperture is Greg it's a bad call at the
end
no a perfectly fine defense
what is an aperture I don't know
I'll say this I think that
um the president needs to come before I
said from the outset right I mean just
say opening that it's a domain awareness
the aperture gets bigger you know that
we knew that we were just seeing if you
knew that yeah oh okay the President
should come before the country and give
a briefing you don't have to be a
classified briefing you're hearing
Democrat Republicans alike I think the
country wants to know lawmakers are
entitled to know as well and for
whatever reason they've decided not to
do it if you don't do it you obviously
invite theories is some far-fetched some
more believable but I think it's
incumbent upon the president to do that
to judge your right the geopolitical
there are two strands of this I think
two big strands of this big this China
relationship one is geopolitical which
is becoming increasingly disconcerting
the other is how intertwined and
dependent we as consumers and U.S firms
banking retail Etc are on China at some
point those two things are going to
collide if not already and as we think
of about a 21st century Cold War they
are our Cold War adversary but they're
different and more formidable than
Russia because they're richer they're
smarter they have better technology and
frankly they're a vowed uh purpose for
the 21st century is to be the dominant
nation in the 21st century they see that
we were the strongest in the 20th they
want the 21st which is why I was hoping
last week President Biden would not only
have addressed this in the speech but
might have even gone as far as to
outline a bite in China Doctrine he
needs to do that sooner rather than the
Biden China Doctrine
that's all that's not it's not fair
up next he's been opening a lot of
apertures
oh I didn't know what that means I don't
even know if I should be insulted I
think that's redundant by the way you
can't open an aperture what's redundant
well you've been in Latin I wanna Brian
Kilmeade I want you to do me a favor I
want you to click to subscribe to the
Fox News YouTube page this is the only
way that I know for sure that you're not
going to miss any great commentary any
great news bites any great interviews
coming your way on Fox you can get it
all here on YouTube so subscribe right
now